welcome back small business owners
across the country say they face an
awful choice
because obeying the law often means
destroying their businesses
alex hogan joins us from new york where
bar owners are pushing back
against some of these coveted lockdowns
hi alex
hi leland all of these restrictions
really taking a toll on some small
businesses and a yelp
economic impact report finding that in
the first six months of the pandemic
about
800 businesses closed every day in
michigan
indoor dining is banned while the state
is on
pause but some restaurants there are
pushing back still
opening despite these guidelines to try
to stay afloat
in staten island new york the back and
forth continues over a pub that declared
itself an autonomous zone to skirt
coveted regulations
mack's public house reopened last night
against the state's orders
police even arrested one of the
co-owners this week in new jersey
indoor gatherings are limited to 10
people photos sparking outrage
capturing dozens of members of the new
york young republicans club
at the maritime park restaurant without
masks among them
matt gates new jersey governor phil
murphy blasting the florida congressman
for breaking the state's
regulations what a fool
he and they should be ashamed of
themselves he is not welcome i hope
you're watching matt
you are not welcome in new jersey and
frankly i don't ever want you back in
this state
to send a lifeline to the country small
business owners two competing proposals
we count of this week house speaker
nancy pelosi and senate minority leader
chuck schumer
backing a 908 billion dollar stimulus
plan this week
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
supporting a roughly
50 billion dollar plan this past week
in november we saw that the new jobs
report added about 245
000 jobs but that is the fewest since
april after we've seen these months and
months of people struggling to get by
while
a vaccine could be around the corner
it's still a bleak
outlook for some of these businesses
trying to stay afloat until then
leland check out matt gates's twitter
for his response to the governor of new
jersey alex hogan
in new york alex thank you